he works super fast he shoots One camera
at a time nothing more than one camera
he doesn't have a video Village he has a
small hand
Monitor and he was watching my close-ups
on like a hand Monitor and he wasn't
happy with like stuff the first uh scene
we did my stuff was basically shot
chronologically and the first scene we
did is the scene on the train is pretty
intimate scene with me and Killian
Murphy and uh
and Chris was like uh he made me do 14
takes of my closeup and this is a guy
that does like three takes typically and
this is your first scene you're shooting
day now were you thinking about oh my
God everybody's looking at me Killian
Murphy thinks I'm terrible I'm bombing
I'm gonna get fired all these things
you're thinking of you're obsessing oh
consciously in the moment and it doesn't
help that Chris is like I don't know
what you're
doing and I'm I'm thinking to myself
well because I'm on that tiny monitor
you know but he wanted something
different than what I was planning and
you know I had to adjust on the fly but
you don't argue with Chris Nolan out of
respect because he doesn't he doesn't
he's one of those directors he doesn't
demand respect He commands respect he is
the hardest working man on the set he's
involved in everything there is no you
know a
doing half his job for him he isn't
taking a break he never sits down he
never goes to the bathroom J so he's on
OIC what's that he's on
OIC that's right that's what he's on I
was I love this genius guy and like all
I want to do is make him happy so we did
takes and the next scene we did um we
did nine takes of my closeup and and at
the end of it he came up to me and he
saidwell nine takes it's better than 14
which is what you did the first
time so but he's being
sarcastic oh yeah but he's the opposite
of like and there was one day where we
did a scene and I went up to him and I
said was that good and he said he
fishing for
compliments he really doesn't like that
really so let me ask you this because
I've done this before where I'm on set
and he the director wants something
and he's giving me now notes and I don't
even understand the notes like I'm just
going to do another take but I don't
even really get what he's saying and I
feel like if I keep asking him I don't
understand it's going to make it worse
I'll just do it and see if I get lucky
with my abilities right did you feel
like after eight nine 10 you're just
like oh I'm just trying something
different did you ever look at Killian
Murphy and
go here we go yeah no because Chris you
know Chris has so much brevity in the
way he gives notes he's so specific and
so smart about how to get what he wants
out of you I
just I guess I was just in a place of
stuck in what I had been doing for
months in the auditioning process and
and then you know what I had
planned and um it also like the literal
space that we were in that train car was
Tiny IMAX cameras are massive they're
like three times the size and it was him
his DP ho hoyaa uh Killian literally
like off camera sandwiched up against
the wall and so there's not a lot of
like mental space physical space
claustrophobic yeah and so I think what
I ended up happening was I was very much
here and I needed to be very much here
and it took me 14 takes to get there ah
it probably took me 10 and he gave me
four good ones do you go how many did
kilan Murphy get how many takes on that
yeah less a lot L did you go home
afterwards and call your wife and say I
I don't know I don't I this could be my
my first and last
day yes you did you were that nervous
you're gonna get fired 100% 100% yeah
you know that movie specifically because
you look at that cast and you go man
there's some heavy [__] hitters in
this cast yeah bro you know Downey and
Oldman and and and and kilan and the
list goes on it and Emily Blunt and
Florence Pew and you just go man I I
can't suck in this you know if I had a
smaller role I could kind of suck if I
wanted to let him suck in that scene I
have to like [__] chew this thing up
and spit it out I have to make something
of this and yeah I was really nervous I
but everyone was everyone in that movie
was kind of like wow was it's it's a
murderer's roow it's one of the best
casts ever and you know one best
ensembles and it was just a murderer
role you know I remember um Jason Clark
came in to do his scenes and I did my
one scene with him and even he was like
a little like and he had a lot of
dialogue too a lot of dialogue and he
has heavy moments and you could see that
he was up to the challenge and that he
was gonna nail it but it came from a
place of I better nail it there wasn't
it wasn't the most laidback
environment yeah you got to step up it's
like I I know my lines inside out
reverse forward I I don't care if it's
two lines I'm GNA know at a million
percent. plus you're shooting on IMAX
film so it's not like digital where you
can do this all day like they're running
out of money as you [__] up every time
you [__] up it's a big deal yeah and so
you know it was just uh did they pay you
well did you get paid
well um yeah all right yeah what it was
it was surprising actually it wasn't bad
um good yeah